ein ganz normaler arbeitstag beginnt
christina tv wallau man seit 20 jahren
steht sie auf der bühne in einem der
größten freizeitparks deutschlands im
phantasialand bei köln sie genießt jeden
einzelnen tag im park
ich lebe in einem märchen da wo die
menschen urlaub machen er arbeite ich
ich brenne für meinen job ich könnte mir
nicht vorstellen was anders zu arbeiten
auch nach 20 jahren auf der bühne
liebe ich diesen ort und meine arbeit
immer mehr
die gebürtige bulgarin tritt auf einer
der drei großen bühnen im park auf die
47 jährige ist in bester form hängend in
der luft einen spagat zu machen ein
kinderspiel was sie heute kann verdankt
sie der rhythmischen sportgymnastik
einer sportart die in kommunistischen
bulgarien sehr belebt war
15 jahre lang war sie leistungssportler
den bereits als kind gewann sie medien
nach der wende verließ jeder heimat
befehle andere ab
das ist ein schweres thema für unsere
generation wir haben diese sportart
nicht nur trainiert wie haben sie gelebt
aber nach vielen jahren harte arbeit hat
sich alles drastisch verändert der
kommunismus ist gang es kam die
demokratie aber vielleicht war es eine
falsch verstandene demokratie sehr viele
von uns haben bulgarien verlassen denn
dort konnten wir uns nicht
weiterentwickeln es gab kaum arbeit für
uns und im ausland waren bulgarische
sportler willkommen
1999 kam christina nach deutschland
macht zwei jahren im zirkus entdeckte
sie den freizeitpark und blieb
mittlerweile steht sie nicht nur auf der
bühne christina ist teamleiterin in der
abteilung künstler alle schätzen ihrer
erfahrung und ihren teamgeist
sich hilft uns bei problemen über selbst
für uns ihre arbeit ist hocheffizient
und das wohlbefinden des teams ist ihr
sehr wichtig
den download eines city muss
seit vier jahren ganz silvina neben
frisst ihn auf der bühne aber auch
außerhalb des parks unternehmen sie
gerne etwas zusammen welches team er
zeit hat denn so widmet viele stunden er
alten liebe der rhythmischen
sportgymnastik
im borner turnverein springt selbst
trainerin ein wenn es nötig ist sie
freut sich wenn sie zeit mit den
kleinsten sportlerinnen verbringen kann
und ihnen etwas beibringt
ich habe mir in bulgarien als
vierjährige angefangen hier in
deutschland fangen die kinder etwas
später an mit sechs oder sieben sie
können sich trotzdem gut entwickeln
dafür ist aber viel leidenschaft nötig
in ihrer freizeit nichts ist ina trikots
für die wettkämpfe der kleinen
sportlerinnen die mädchen leben die
bunten kostüme
[Musik]
mit diesem trikot startete 2001
christinas karriere im phantasialand
damals an ihrer seite vier weitere
sportlerinnen aus ihrer heimat seitdem
sind viele neuer bulgarischer dessen und
künstler gekommen andere sind gegangen
wie üblich in diesem geschäft sie aber
ist geblieben denn der park ist ihr
leben sagt sie auch ihren ehemann hat
sich hier kennengelernt einen stuntman
aus großbritannien
im jahr 2005 haben wir geheiratet und
seitdem fühlt sich das leben wie urlaub
das leben mit meiner frau ist sehr
leicht möglich glückliches leben
und du warst auch blut mit mir ja habe
ich
pohl und wie die szene sind zufrieden
deutschland hat ihnen vieles gegeben nur
eins könnte noch besser werden ich
wünsche mir dass man den migranten mehr
möglichkeiten gibt sich authentischer zu
füllen hier im park ist es nicht von
bedeutung woher du kommst aber im alltag
spürt man schon dass das eine rolle
spielt wenn man das verändern könnte
wäre das toll und gleich geht es zur
nächsten show nicht nur beruflich denn
unser leben ist eine bühne wie christine
sagt